you win an Emmy and rightfully so
because you are brilliant on this show
thank you're playing Zach Galifianakis
is mop I am on the show and I think
what's really stunning your performance
is fantastic but you really make no
effort it act like a woman no I know
it's it's brilliant I think we have a
picture yeah there you are you thank you
it's like you can crack the atom because
so many times when a guy dresses up in
place a they do something you know like
whoohoo you know and you know who yeah
you don't do that at home tonight oh
yeah
yeah well I think the director Jonathan
kreisel who you know is very funny and
louis c.k and Zach and all those guys
you know I don't think I don't think it
was a big discussion right I think we
just I said I'm not gonna change my
voice he goes okay was it who who called
you about my roles
yeah the whole thing was we yeah louis
c.k called me and goes hey Louis I go
hey Louie and you know like if someone
was named Conan you'd feel that would be
like hey hi yeah I'm late finally the
meet yes and he said we're doing the
show with Zach Galifianakis in he's here
we want you to do a part I go yeah you
kidding me that's fantastic
yeah I mean you know they're so good
they're brilliant the show is brilliant
you know what's interesting is that
you're you're playing a mom and your mom
is play such a big part in your stand-up
over I hear she's a big subject well she
must have been a powerful influence on
you he was I mean even today like today
I walked in a restaurant and I go could
we get some extra butter please
another guy since they'll let us eat
your party first I said okay but don't
use the word lettuce it's a layer yeah
you know that's a comics comics Joe I
mean yes yeah for the other comics right
audience often goes lettuce did he
mention lettuce yeah yeah now you are
I've heard you say that you're trying to
be healthier now yes how is it going do
you think you look do I look good I have
lost you know like some people tell her
I heard you lost a hundred pounds I go
when I lost 35 pounds but you know like
and you know I try to cuz people
oftentimes go oh you did huh and they
look at you oh I know well picture me as
a forest and the tree is missing
[Laughter]
you are I'm just curious how did you
lose the 35 pounds I wired half my mouth
shut yeah makes two on one side yeah
yeah
you